tu es le sentiment à l'heure concernant
un personnage central et le régime va
enchaîner évidemment qui est jean marc
ayrault le prémisse est ce que vous avez
l'impression à l'intérieur de l'équipe
qui va rester complètement complètement
je pense que otor la presse l'a montré
du doigt il ya quelques temps au temps
aujourd'hui ville et je trouve très
consolidé très stabilisé il est en
harmonie avec la politique que mène
françois hollande ça marche très bien
entre eux il est plutôt largement
respectée par ses ministres qui reprend
en main quand il le faut je trouve qu'il
est consolidé dans cette période et je
vois pas qui pourrait remplacer ce
premier ministre là aujourd'hui